cette semaine l'actualité c'est aussi le
dépistage géant de lakovic 19 organisée
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
nous vous en reparlerons dans un instant
avec notre invité
avant cela le témoignage de xavier
quintin directeur des activités de l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
au plus haut de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
les services de réanimation yvelinois
ont accueilli jusqu'à 190 patients il en
a fait partie hospitalisation placé en
réanimation puis transférés il est
aujourd'hui guérie il témoigne auprès de
ces deux prêts de mélanie poképark à
premières suspicions et vers le chu mars
à peu près où je me ferais un peu
fébrile et j'ai réellement la fièvre à
partir du barrage le 27
les symptômes effectivement se sont
aggravées la fièvre augmenté à plus de
39 depuis cinq jours quasiment et je
suis par ailleurs en contact avec une
infirmière pour un autre souci est saine
concrètement qui va me dire d'appeler le
je pense que moi et ça c'est important
de le dire qu'à ce monde moi je ne leur
ai pas encore fait je monte assez
rapidement après être passé par là le
beuc de déstockage de déchocage
d'urgence je passe donc en chambre à
l'étagé
relativement rapidement agréablement
surpris je me rappelle de cette cette
sensation et puis après c'est un petit
peu le trou noir j'irai puisque mon état
va s'aggraver l'enjeu longtemps en
chambre j'estime vert vers minuit à peu
près à 5 heures du matin mon état
s'aggrave fortement très fortement et
très soudainement comme d'ailleurs dans
la plupart des cas d'aggravation donc je
suis placé en réanimation effectivement
sans en être conscient
j'y reste jusqu'au 1er avril et le 1er
avril a décimé plus de m'envoyer à
rennes par tgv oui je commence à
reprendre confiance en fait au moment où
je vais être exclu et l'explication
elle intervient le 7 avril donc au bout
d'une dizaine de jours des problèmes de
concentration d'attention et de
mémorisation et ça en discutant avec des
médecins par la suite j'ai su que
c'était un des éléments étaient assez
fréquent chez les malades atteints du
mobile et notamment notamment jeu tiré
de façon assez sévères la deuxième la
deuxième c'est qu'elle s'appelle
d'articulation à l'épaule gauche
notamment au bras gauche et des
problèmes d'amplitude peut pas faire
tous les gestes que je faisais avant et
la troisième c'est qu'elle sait belle
cicatrice a en fait dû à l'intubation
leur petit peu avant de transférer
jusqu'à mon réveil rennes pas
outre-mesure inquiet sur l'avenir
maintenant je me protège même si
effectivement je fais partie des
personnes qui pour l'instant sont très
peu susceptibles d'être contaminés mais
est pas exclu qu à terme je puisse
l'être